the lies that the ruling class are
pushing about puberty blockers and
transiting the kids are so hideous i
can't even read it without my blood
pressure going up i'm a pretty cool guy
i'm pretty much cool as a cucumber this
stuff i read this tweet from this guy
jack turbin who is just such a creep
it's just a nasty little creep it's it's
hard to
read what he's trying to do which is
which is effectively to abuse little
kids call let's call it what it is i
know there's a debate over can we use
the term groomer or not rumor i will
leave that for another day there is no
way you can read this this guy wants to
trans little kids and put them on
cross-sex hormones and mutilate their
bodies that is child abuse that's all it
is and this guy jack turbin he's a child
abuser and maybe he doesn't think he is
or maybe he knows he is or i don't know
i don't really care how he views himself
that is what he is doing and he's
pushing lies about this process
it's really dangerous because there are
probably parents out there who are going
to be confused whose kids are going to
be convinced that they're transgender
because of social movements and because
of creeps in the public schools and and
lots of other factors in our society and
they're not going to know what to do and
they're going to want to do what's best
for their kids and they're going to
inadvertently pump their kids full of
poison it's horrible this guy jack
turbin says that puberty blockers are
temporary and reversible it's just not
true
i've got here a report about a study
it's come out in the new atlantis
journal
it's called growing pains problems with
puberty suppression in treating
transgender dysphoria this is
co-authored by very serious scientists
paul h ruse a professor at washington
university school of medicine lawrence s
mayer a scholar in residence at johns
hopkins school of medicine
which let's not forget johns hopkins
pioneered the transgender surgery
and then ended up shutting it down
because it wasn't helping anybody but
this is probably the top medical school
in the country
uh this guy lawrence mayer is also at
arizona state and paul mchugh who was at
johns hopkins he's a distinguished
professor of psychiatry johns hopkins
university of medicine former
psychiatrist and chief at johns hopkins
also who pioneered this transgender
surgery these guys are all pointing to a
huge
increase in young people getting these
kind of transgender
experiments
being done on them
and they're saying this is really
dangerous this is really bad first the
paper says that the treatment is not
necessarily
reversible that actually
what the scientists point out is quote
there are virtually no published reports
even case studies of adolescents
withdrawing from puberty suppressing
drugs and then resuming the normal
pubertal development typical for their
sex so while creeps like this guy jack
turbine say oh the pube just put your
kid on puberty blockers if you know if
your little boy reaches for a barbie
doll look better to just delay puberty
than to have him discover he's
transgender after it's he's gone through
an irreversible puberty and don't worry
the blockers will be uh will be
temporary
or reversible there's no there's no
evidence of that second
these scientists take on the idea that
treatment is harmless
now puberty blockers what they do is
they pump you full of hormones and they
they
they
suppress secondary sex characteristics
from developing
what these guys write is puberty
suppression hormones prevent the
development of secondary sex
characteristics arrest bone growth
decrease bone accretion
prevent full organization and maturation
of the brain and inhibit fertility we're
talking about really really dangerous
stuff there's so many cases of this one
of the main
puberty blocking drugs is lupron
many
patients are not exposed to or they're
not told about the full side effects of
these the extreme side effects that you
can have from from lupon from the
puberty blocking just temporary
reversible stuff uh joint severe joint
pain osteoporosis compromised immune
systems severe mental health issues such
as depression and even suicidal ideation
the fda has received 24 000 reports of
adverse reactions half of which the
agency itself has admitted are quite
serious just to give you an example of
some
some cases of this
and you can just google it
adverse side effects from puberty
blockers
one person suffered not only constant
pain but strange rashes severe
osteoporosis and multiple surgeries
expert witnesses in court cases brought
here have have concluded that plaintiffs
in these cases have suffered extreme
bone density loss and other symptoms as
a result of lupron beginning at age 17.
and the the most important finding of
these reviews
shows that 62.5 percent of patients
treated with lupron for in lupron can be
used for completely different conditions
endometriosis other conditions like that
had not regained baseline estrogen
levels by one year after stopping so the
idea that oh don't worry you go off it
you'll go right back to normal that's
just complete bs and then finally the
idea that puberty blockers are
cautionary
is
absurd the argument that creeps like
jack turbin and these other weird creepy
child abusing column groomers if you
want to people are doing is they're
saying look it's better for your kid to
go on the puberty blockers now
than to let puberty set in
because if the puberty sets in then
their their depression their anxiety
their their
suicidal suicidality is going to get
much much worse there's no evidence of
that actually in most cases gender
confusion before puberty is going to
just go away after puberty the author's
right gender identity for children is
elastic that is it can change over time
and plastic that is it can be shaped by
forces like parental approval and social
conditions
and unfortunately what they point out is
this transgender
treatment it's not treatment it's child
abuse
will actually harden feelings of gender
dysphoria so not only will it not make
it better it'll actually make it worse
so that those those rates of suicide
anxiety depression they're going to
they're going to stick around in there i
really encourage you
i really encourage you to read up on
this sort of thing
but
when i when i think about just at a very
human level when i think about people
like jack durbin when i think about
these creeps in with positions of
authority with the white lab coats
sitting there talking to a confused and
desperate parent of a kid who maybe has
some sexual identity issues and saying
what we recommend if you really love
your kid if you really love your kid and
you don't want your kid to die or kill
himself then what you need to do is
mutilate his body and pump him full of
cross-sex hormones
and don't worry it'll be if you want to
reverse it it'll be fine and then and
then these parents do it they fall into
the lies of these predators like jack
durbin and then their kids end up with
massive bone density loss on walkers
with horrible psychiatric conditions
it's sick it's child abuse people like
this guy jack turbin and others who are
pushing this these quacks
these psychopaths who are pushing this
should at the very least be imprisoned
for life there should be a law against
this
they should be prosecuted and they
should face the consequences for these
prosecutions i can think
of few things worse
than child abuse abuse of confused
vulnerable little kids
the regret that their parents are going
to feel after they've been lured into
this and these
sickos need to be brought into line by
our law no question
about it it's so corrupt it's so corrupt
because we covered this a week or two
ago
the the
even the government is coming in and
saying no parents it's really good you
need to trans your kids it's really
important that's what the science is and
where are they getting that from they're
getting that from organizations such as
the trevor project which are conducting
studies and surveys on the effectiveness
of tran transgendering the little kids
and where's the trevor project getting
their money from the trevor project is
getting their money from the
pharmaceutical companies like abvay that
are producing the drugs to trans the
kids it's so
freaking corrupt and we should not stand
for this someday
you're going to have generations from
now let's say 100 years from now 200
years from now you are going to read
about
you're not going to you're going to be
dead but you're going to have future
generations reading about what we did to
little kids with this insane sexual
psychosis fetish whatever the hell this
transgender thing is we are going to
see future generations read about this
and say what sickos those people were in
the 2020s in the 2030s that they would
conduct these kind of medical
experiments on little kids that were so
abusive
a lot of it
a lot of it stemming from confusion a
lot of it stemming from corruption right
now text knowles to 98 98 98 if your
retirement account has been heavy on
stocks for a while i got great news for
you you won that's amazing the value of
your ira or 401k has probably ballooned
thanks to the longest bull market run in
u.s history
and after every bull run comes a
recession right now stock valuations are
at historic highs
only seen before the great depression
and the dot-com crash there's the good
news and then there's the bad news in
the face of teetering global stability
stock volatility is way up so maybe it's
time to take some of your chips off the
table secure your winnings and your
future with gold from birch gold right
now birch gold will help you convert
those gains that you have on paper into
a real physical asset and it will be in
a tax sheltered account nice try irs go
get started right now text knowles canon
wles 298 9898 with thousands of
satisfied customers and an a plus rating
from the better business bureau birch
gold can help you protect your savings
text knowledge k wles to 98 98 98 to get
a free info kit on gold no obligation to
get this info go do it right now text
knolls skinner wlas 298-9898 to protect
at least some of your winnings with gold
glad you liked that clip i am now please
ring the bell subscribe get all the
videos don't miss a single second
go to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play get the audio podcast we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]